The Joe Rogan Experience I want to hear
more conspiracies
you know what [__] the submarines [__]
the submarines the hunter Biden stuff
though
UFOs UFOs it's Project Blue we used to
be all in our UFOs I was a UF dude I was
the UFO is there ice in there no yeah uh
no
do you remember when
um you and I first got into Zacharias
hell yeah I don't know you know how I
got into it you know you know I remember
how we got into because remember Gina
the girl I used to make music with yes
she was like you know she was uh you
know at some party and she we we were
working on some music because last night
this guy told me about
um there's this guy who who wrote about
some transcripts or some something like
that and he said he was telling me that
that we're created by aliens to mine
gold and I remember like what she goes
yeah he was telling me about this I go
what's his name his name was like Jody
because of my friend Jody was telling me
about this guy and I'm like can you call
him call him up and because it made
sense to me like like wait a minute we
were we were created as slaves to mine
gold for this other planet I was all
balls deep in the UFOs so so I called
this [__] oh my god do you
remember what you were telling Gina and
goes yeah there's this guy named
Zachariah sitchin look him up he wrote a
book called the 12th Planet and I'm like
okay so boom got into him like oh [__] I
dude I believe that [__] they got me
Hook Line and Sinker man but um yeah you
know and then so so Eddie do you think
that they do you believe that
whistleblower like he's actually seen
the uh I believe a lot of the people
that see UFOs really believe they see it
and they just get set up I think they're
just but they're not seeing UFOs they're
seeing like there's maybe a drone
Holograms drones some high-level [__]
they're pushing it so hard it's so
obvious that's so [__] awesome
it goes mainstream I'm like what's going
on here come on and then at the same
time the Biden crime family shit's
coming out dog all that [__] where they
they said ruli Rudy Giuliani was [__]
crazy he's a crackpot they do two three
years ago they made him look like a
[__] crackpot and all he was doing I
got the laptop right here we got it all
right here and the scariest part was
they got 51 Intelligence Officers to
sign off on it
scary scary scary scary you had 51 guys
[__] yeah oh my God
scary they knew that it was legit in
2019. dude scary that's scary that's
great have you looked up your lap what's
scary is no one is facing any
repercussions zero he got a slap what
about all those guys not just him I'm
talking about the people who told
everyone that it was Russians they
suffer no Concepts and you know what
they stick with it though because
they're saying that that the the justice
system is corrupt by saying that it's
not yeah they go oh they're lying so
it's just a lot of confusion thank you
Jamie dude I went to the website where
they released all his pictures and [__]
that boy wild boy he looks like a good
time I gotta be honest can I have the
ball ice I'll get some more that is no
yeah I want the ball I want the ball too
but I love you thank you I owe you I
know you conspiracy is best the best
when 51 Intelligence Officers
say it's Russian disinformation when
it's not and we do it
scary what kind of country are we living
in and all the [__] they're throwing at
Trump they're trying to get rid of that
[__]
you are not keeping your mouth shut what
the [__] is that I'm keeping my mouth
shut it's just [__] right now
no no I'm just saying what's already out
there okay
you know what I mean I'm not trying to
get [__] killed I'm good I got him I
got it let me get some of that Joe
dude they could have got pen guys to
sign off on and that would have been a
lot they went 50 because they know they
know they get 50 it's gonna be no doubt
everyone's gonna believe that [__] right
and they stick with it even today the
mainstream media they still stick with
it let me ask you this why do they still
keep singing the National Anthem in a
boxing fight because that [__] takes so
much time